speaking of going to your hometown and
see if people have changed right i do
have
i do have a
i do have a funny story about someone
who i met in my university town
that has definitely changed in a way
that i didn't imagine
okay so what happened is i went to see
some of my mates who are living in
bristol right now which was my
my city where i went to university i
went to university of bristol
um and so we're at this club right
and um we we meet we meet a guy there
and this guy um who i wasn't you know i
wasn't very close to him in university
but uh
word on the street was he was the type
of guy who if you needed certain
substances
that was the guy to call right
okay and um so you know i'm just you
know having a casual chat and uh he
asked me what i'm doing and i was like i
started talking about japan i saw start
talking about
being a youtuber living in japan and
stuff like that
and he goes oh i do something about
japan now and i'm like what the [ __ ] do
you do now what is this person it's like
like to to preface this is a guy who
applied to love island once right he is
he is not the kind of guy who i would
expect has
any interest
in japan at all right and he goes oh
yeah like um
i uh i deal in ideal pokemon cards now i
was like [ __ ] off
what what what what is this and he's
like ha ha i'm like how are you getting
pokemon cards i was like oh i love
pokemon i've always loved it and i was
like how are you getting pokemon cards
and i'm like gone
i've got
contacts and i'm just like
why why did you have to make it sound
like that
i'm sorry
and so and so and so he takes me he
takes me over to one side right
he's just like
you're gone go on come here come here
look
i've got a good deal if you're
interested in pokemon go i was just like
i was just like what what
i was like you're taking the piss you're
taking a piss and it's like mate i just
sent off i just sent off a shiny mewtwo
it got graded nine grade nine shiny
mewtwo mate first edition it can be
yours i'm selling it but i'll give you
i'll give you a good deal i'll give you
a good deal and i'm just like this is
the weirdest [ __ ] offshoot of
breaking bad i've ever seen
we got
and so yeah like like so this this this
guy went through a complete career
change
apparently and is now
as a and is now a dealing pokemon card
i've got contacts and game freak
just pulls out a bunch of business cards
the whole weirdest aspect of this whole
pokemon card was what it was that people
were sending cards
their cards
for logan paul to open
why why
so that they could be in the video
there's some kind of like modern cucking
that i'm not aware of where like you
don't get enjoyment of opening your own
things now you have to sound to someone
else who can open them but better
like what is this what what [ __ ] gear
are we in where we don't get enjoyment
it's like it's like well i'd go and buy
a bunch of gacha and i'd make joey log
in my account and do it because he does
it better than me i mean that also is a
thing yeah yeah it got gotten all these
pools for me and i guess isn't this
what is it
modern cocking is this like this is what
is this when does this begin why is this
thing i'm pretty sure there's like a
bunch of like ginseng youtubers who get
they do yeah they get like tech doesn't
like yeah yeah like take like pulls for
other players it's like what i mean i
feel like it's just like living
vicariously through this one person
right because i guess but it's like with
pokemon cards it feels like a weird
extra step where you would send these
like extremely valuable cards to be
opened like yeah do they do they come
back to the past yeah they come back to
the person
i i think it's i i think i think i kind
of get it because it's kind of like
sharing
you're like like like this it's all
about the experience right because
you're you're sharing the experience
with say your favorite content creator
because you know there's there's a
difference you know there's there is a
difference doing it yourself and like
having the freak out by yourself and
like doing it as like a group i was like
okay
it kind of makes sense i guess it just
feels like this weird kind of what year
are we in it's a bit of an extra some
people just don't don't want to open up
their own things anymore i'm gonna
invite gone over to open up my [ __ ]
dyson vacuum cleaner just so i can get
the true experience of how it does watch
him take off
howard dyson should be on box because
god will do it better than me isn't it
weird like like okay i understand it's a
shared experience but it's weird yeah
it is strange right it is strange it's a
bit strange i don't think it's strange i
i i would you do it would you send off
your cards for someone else to open no
but i would if if i'm like say opening
like a rare pack i'd want my boys in
there i'd be like i wouldn't want to do
it by myself i want to like i want to
like share the experience for you guys
boys 5 pm
i'm opening up i have a fresh pack right
here
non-crinkled cards
look it's it's just like part of the fun
is is the shared experience of just
doing this exciting thing you know but
when does it not become your thing it's
not your thing anymore it's someone
else's yeah what do you mean if you send
your cards off to logan paul to open up
do they still does he send them back
yeah no no no
there's a massive difference it's like
you being cut out right yeah there's a
massive difference between like you
gathering your friends to do it in front
of your friends and then sending your
cards to someone that you don't know who
maybe you don't know
if you give me the cards yeah that's it
yeah yeah i mean i mean it's not with
extra steps but like
you're sharing that with like say one of
the biggest content creators
on the platform right so it's like so
it's like yep
do this role for me joey i can't i can't
you do it joe you do the problem is that
like the majority of like if they're
like streaming on twitch the majority of
the chat isn't gonna be like oh this is
the card that was sent by this person
holy [ __ ] i guess i kind of get it now
that you say it like that i do kind of
understand that you could get more
enjoyment i've seen other people react
to your thing yeah yeah
but it is just strange isn't it what
what level of consumerism are we on
right now this is we buy things for
ourselves for someone else to open for
yeah what what what level is this like
just make sure to send a bag of
capitalism is this this is what they
they're gonna use in like comp other
communist societies be like look look at
it they don't even buy their own stuff
anymore they buy it for someone else to
open isn't it weird look at this
like
i think okay i kind of get it now but
it's strange yeah it's a bit weird
you have to admit objectively it sounds
bizarre i mean you can make anything
sound weird if you like put it in a
tried way
but like i mean like
i mean like
that's that's kind of like the same kind
of argument when let's play it starts to
get popular right
like it's it's it's a bit weird you know
i mean you're kind of just watching
someone play a video game and they're
not even good at the video game well
okay i would argue with that one though
it's not like i'm buying a physical copy
of the game yeah and then sending it to
the left
i don't have a copy anymore yeah and
then i watch you play it yeah it's it's
not like i'm sending a game to the let's
play and then they're like just after
you finish it just give me back the game
but then again people do buy games yeah
streamers but then they normally do that
because they want to get they want to
see them have the experience that they
had
so it's it's it's all about the shared
experience right and then that's i guess
i guess i do understand the feeling it's
just
it does seem strange to me that this
even was a thought at first glance
someone was like i'm gonna send my cards
to logan paul
[Music]
it's like i think this is the way you're
saying the sentence yeah
it's it's akin to like being cucked in
my mind
it's like i'm gonna send my girlfriend
i can't i won't get as much satisfaction
out of doing this as i would watching
someone else do this yeah
i don't know it is kind of more
satisfying right i mean i i i
you're telling is
you're into your own [ __ ] that's cool
dude no i mean like for example with
gacha it is like a lot more fun to pull
on streams it comes back to gadgets it
does always come back to catch all right
but i mean that's that's kind of peak
entertainment 2021 i mean that's that's
what pokemon cards are right yeah it's
just physical
it's just physical gotcha right yeah
this is the loot box
so it's it's a lot funner to do with
your mates like every time i remember
when we were like addicted to art nights
every time every time joey was in the
office he was like i'm going to do a
pool and we're like oh
let's let's see what he gets and it's
it's a lot more fun to do with mates
because if you don't get it then your
mates will be like haha you're a [ __ ]
idiot
you're buying packs for joey to paul
because because you get the cards back
so it's but let's say yeah yeah i guess
you do yeah yeah
yeah but i guess like the equivalence of
that is like i'm gonna give you a
hundred bucks to pull on arc nights but
once you finish the pause i need you to
send me 100 bucks back yeah it's like
that's a little weird
i mean it's more like you're just giving
the phone to another person joe joey you
do the pool for me you don't i trust
your gadget giving your significant
other to someone else for one evening
that you can view while you sit back and
enjoy the show
i'm not crazy right with this comparison
no i get what you're coming yeah from
yeah but it's just now that i think
about it it is
not as weird
as i initially thought
okay that's as weird as that okay
is it weird that we don't find that
weird anymore let me let me show you
another idea okay okay
so you know you know like you watch
movies and animes and stuff like that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that like imagine instead
of watching a two-hour movie you could
watch
three blokes sitting on a set just
arguing about chicken breasts and
chicken thighs how's that down how's
that sound sounds like quality content
that's cool that's called
live choices i have one question okay
why subscribe
how do i sign up for that
i suppose and what would you why do you
think why do you think trash taste is
successful
[Laughter]
what do you think a very good question
podcast really is a sucking our own dick
podcast
yeah why would someone go and watch us
instead of watching a movie which is
just
objectively better entertainment
i could give like a really deep answer
now that is just like i i feel like i'm
ready for the truth bomb you know i feel
like with with the whole shared
experience thing we're talking about a
lot of people would now crave kind of
like that feeling of
like
a relationship or like a closeness of
someone and people a lot of people can
feel that parasocially by for example
sending their fa their cards to their
favorite streamers or sending some money
for their favorite gadget streamers to
uh
to pull or just watching three blokes
three friends talk for two hours you
know you get that feeling that you're
connected with someone either you have
that feeling of connection even though
that connection isn't technically real
you know and i feel like a lot of
content
nowadays especially with the younger
generation
is got like a lot of the most
a lot of the most successful streamers
and a lot of the most successful content
creators are people who can accurately
represent that feeling of a close
connection a parasocial relationship
let's say um see that was that was that
was that was my deep answer um i'm 14
and this is deep
my meme answer is just it's just
threeplex chang [ __ ]
it's just funny it's just fun
i guess because we we don't you know we
didn't strive to have that right we just
make we just talk
but it's always much deeper we do it for
our own self-satisfaction
we just want to make it show we just
change checks i mean we didn't try for
that it just happened by completely